なぁ僕は100万円いるものを受けています
いったいそれは何でしょうか
皆さん来られましたん
実はこのシャツ
2000円雑誌
じゃあ人
大変これも2000円ですっ
もし勝ってだらけ
期待ません
答えは
記事も人ならきていけないようにもの
それはこっちわけだしえっ
4人にかけているも長期合わせてだいたい100万円くらいします
ビールが買うなら5000本以上かいます
キチン日本のでもラーメン部になります
ご紹介いただいた通り僕は耳が聞こえません
まあ上記をつけていますが姉さんに同じを聞こえるわけではありません
ではどれくらいの音の大きされ聞こえないので使用感
皆さん
今のに指を突っ込んで下げてください
グッドトゥ
でください
元気ですか
スコアについてさ
おっ
てください
皆さん聞こえにくいと感じましたん
が調教作ってているときの僕の聞こえることのうちさです
皆さん新宿のガールスターわかりました
なんかモノってばかりてるわけじゃないでしょ
実はこちらで入ったときの僕はこれが私た兄店
なんかことが聞こえるかなって感じ暗くくらいです
想像りますか
さてここに
これはアドところとなぁ実際体験と話しです
彼は my day 者に座ってみましたん
近くに向こうが見て赤ちゃんを抱いてるのかーされましたっ
たとこの子は接近を生きるために声かけようとマリオは行ったら
建てられませんでした
ように私のところは小屋が撮れなかったのでしょう
声をかけるのが怖かったからなぁ
恥ずかしかったから
2日に知らない人に声縦にも言えることですよねー
止められてしまうのもわかります
でも所とかなぁ
また別の家が言ってられませんでしたいっ
これはメロンパン耳が聞こえなかったからです
彼は僕たちがあって声を出すことにあまり自信がなかったからです
誰だよ母さんに気づいてもらうためには
声をかける代わりに畑弟は叩くことしかなかったんですよ
かといって知らない人にいきなりか叩くにもしれないです
また
適用を離れるやんでほかネットにすべきよるとラリーも分かっていたかいいん
彼はどうしようもありませんでした
ではなぜ僕は見ている本当に話せるのか
僕は色中の時に発揮本教室迎えていました
1日2回幼虫に行く前とあるためにマイルかがでしゅ初の練習ンってなったっ
初お礼集合は
下の二つが動かすごい地味な練習0
また自分の場合はうまく発音できているかどうたのかなと言う
命の朴正
大変綺麗ですと
それ練習をサボるアウトなぜかさんアルミに住んで利用中に入って
帰ってきてます
こっぴどく怒られることもたくさんありました
小学校に上がるまで前日前1
だから血が出るくらい練習的な人
君はできないんですけども
向こうして
皆さんの前でお話できる g ある体がはっきり話せるようになったので
はいは本当に感謝っています
課長がある程度を上手くなったら番台と召喚
でもまだまだ壁をたくさん入れておきます
僕が切れ学生の時の話です
学校管理母リーチおばあさんに道をとみられる歌っ
深瀬そのお母さんはあまりはっきりしない声であったので
1人ませんでしたん
これで
しません僕意味が悪いんでもう1回が消えておりませんか
お願いしました
するとお母さん
これ以上話が浮いかなと思ったのか
もういいですと言ってあかねと宇宙のみました
この時の僕は
ショックとした
四季な人に売られだか妙な感覚でしたと
は山
飛行なくても声をかけてしまえしまったと思ったらかもしれません
でも僕にとってはポイントとの距離が遠く感じられた瞬間ですと
これでは逆に僕が道を始めた時の話です
いつもにあったなぁ
スマホ打ち感たっぷりとかね自分で解決することが多いのですが
この時は電池が切れて小さくに使えない状況でした
それで通りを上げているお姉さん人超頼むことしました
ん
暇さえ
大学カードでどうやって行くんですか
お姉さんは武蔵そうな顔で答えてくれました
難しいばカーキっていることができませんでした
ないもう一度切っ返しか
それともとりあえず
ありがとうございましたと言ってカレー戸ノ内町3遊間が言いました
加水通りにはちょっとねぇ冊しかいなかったので
もう一度止めることにしました
すいません
特にが悪いんでもう一度ゆっくりはっきりておりませんか
と言うと
お姉さんは
と体とたらスマホと離脱自分の言ったことを焦らして僕見せてくれたんですよ
この彼女の対応を掲げるし
所
神様が定款通ったんじゃねーかん
思ったりしましたん
この姉さんとバーナーの火の人何が違ったんでしょうか
これはます交流とと聞こえないとナヲタランチュウ jr トムケーション方法を考え
たことだと思います
壊れるとわー
あ聞こえだよかじゃあはっきり話し合おうとか
1弾しようという考えがしさっと取ってくると良いですいい
逆に飛行に言うとは
ここはこのようにこの k ちゃん方法であれば
あなたと話しますよと表明しばいい
このようにを捉えが歩み寄る必要があるんじゃないかと思います
市をあげていたのに
また学校いないとわかった時だ
縦にやめたほうがある
はから
声な村今花島大変台じゃねえ感とメタルかもしれません
ところでみなさん予定します
障害のある人と聞いてどんなにどんなイメージを持ちますか
将来ガールができないかわいそう
将来ば手順に頑張る人
何も知らないからどのように変わればいいのかわからないあるの不安があると思います
音が今日皆さん前で聞こえないと話した時皆さんに分かります
もしくは私は使って花すると思った方もいるかもしれません
これが3強という人にはないでしょうか
入館者な犬紹介
自分の中の当たり前と違うことであって
その当たり前が効いている場所がいるがを分からない
あるいはウィンドくさいと思うかもしれません
皆さん中には障害者に障害の話をたらダメかな
頭皮というかもしれません
そんなことないでしょ
自分自身の謝罪というともっと知ってほしいただ作り帰ってほしいと思っている人は
結構います
ただ全員がではなく特に自分の手話が雲梯できないひとにとっては
植えてほしくないと思います
道を大変てきてや例えていたの場合なる場合
高麗とと話しの大変だ
という先入観が厄介に触れとなるん
宇宙た自民のだってあるかもしれません
またただしメーカーによって
僕はショックを受けることに当たるかもしれません
このように
成里障害者の間に壁があることがあります
健常者と将来シャル壁
壁を速くしたいという思いをずっと待っていました
そこで同じ思いを持っている仲間たちと一緒に
今年の春に22団体プロジェクト5は取ってあげました
健常者と商談者の壁をなくすことを目的として
様々な企画を
をやってみました
このなかのちょっとして先月末に筑波大のサッカー部と一緒には高くはして
つくば市の子どもたちと聞こえない子供だというのは一緒に運動会するとか帰宅を行い
ました
最初の挨拶で簡単の所の紹介して
変わる子供にも牛は覚えてもらい
高台寺の音が多く6型そのきっかけ図りました
ちなみに教えたしまう wiki です
良かったらみなさん覚えてくださいね
匿名
ありがとう
二つ命
頑張る
爪
バグたーーーーに友達
これみちです覚えてくださいまたにあると思います
同会では
聞こえだけど用いたスタッフを得るものもと聞こえない子どものコミュニケーションを
始めるきっかけお値段しました
こういう子どもは最初は首相会社と関わったこともない方とを根強い
甲第1話の時の
ワンダーっていう
思って思っていたのかもしれません
それがパンフを返して
聞こえない子供たちと炊かなきゃ抱かれてまして入管がなくなっているのだが凝った
使うことが分かりました
それはー
こっちははっきり動かしたり
に不利益はいかにしてないのか考えて言っていたん
要素全くないですね
このようにはたった一人で歌いします
炎上さと障害者の旅をなくす
音が会が相見える機会を創り出したい
この想いだけで活動しています
貿易の皆さん家します
生涯なルートで聞いてどんなイメージを持ちますか
かわいそう
できないことがあると思います
でも僕はそのようなに感情縁もは否定しません
むしろそれはいいことだと思います
なぜならなぁ
その感情が
ソーラー三共開始ショーらーさんになった
対応する態度訂正二部拠点において
てくる10%以上に感情だからです
障害者に合った対応するためには
まず関心が非常に歩い
あの赤いシートはできない
かわいそうはないように何かをがことないんです
そして将来について知ったり考えたりした訳
障害者は日常生活の中で
何ができて何ができないのか交換があるのです
このような考えからいい
障害者にはどのような裁量取り動けばいいのかな
オカルトとつながります
道はいた純たと思う
生で対応してくれたお姉さんん
聞こえないと思います
メディアは度情報提供してないという考えから
まずで見せる全体をが入ってきたんだと思います
またらぁぁ
日400名のやめたんバーチャルばいい
口ははっきり6が買ってくれれば僕もなきゃだ完了でき誰の間には会が終わったのかも
しれません
皆さんの中身は
一条性格の名前があるかもしれません
もう
その当たり前の外ことではありません
皆さんに白を狭める可能性のある
ちょっとスターン団体が誤用がです
それは
障害者との対応をくりすませる時の電位がリボンでです
それは皆さんすぐに将来についてしっかり学ぶ機会は少ないと思います
またん
女性学なかれ偶然障害者との退場を繋がれる場面もあると思います
と緑の対応導入すればいいのか
自分自身潜入たをトラウトにはないでしょうか
対応した時に相手ができなかったなぁ
マリオマウントはどうしてできないだろう愛想の良い
そんな先入観があれば1回市長選夕刊をたが来てはどうでしょうか
そうすれば皆さんの視野も広がり
それが生姜者と壁を取り払う2時
献上さと障害者
共に反し女屋いる社会できれいになると思います
あとを出したい